go
all right so I'll be talking about the
program that we'll be organizing in
summer 2025 on cryptography so this is
uh you know with all these wonderful
people uh Dan Bon Ed Bo Shafi yishai and
Daniel
Wix okay so modern cryptography was born
as a subfield of thetical computer
science late last century and
essentially as a bridge towards
information security and for much of its
early years the focus was on you know
Secure Storage and and transmission of
information and over the last two
decades slowly with the emergence of new
and new technologies the focus has
shifted towards the following two
questions the first is how can we
securely compute on data of users while
maintaining the privacy of the of the
data and the second is how can we verify
that the computations that we perform on
these data sets are actually correct and
there are basic questions about the
assumptions that we need to solve these
problems and how efficiently can we
solve these
problems so so to to tackle some of
these questions uh in 2015 about eight
years ago a program was organized at
Simon Institute on cryptography uh which
was a tremendous success um based on the
reports that I saw there were roughly
185 reported research papers uh you know
including many many breakthrough results
and in fact many subsequent
breakthroughs that have happened in
cryptography in the last 8 years can be
traced back to uh you know the the
foundations that were laid down in this
program and um you know the program was
uh had a high participation and you know
lots of
activities so building on the success of
this program and again you know all the
activities that have happened in
cryptography in the recent years we are
organizing u a new programming
cryptography in uh 2025 so this program
will have three main themes uh the First
theme will be program ofation uh the
second will be secure multiparty
computation and the third will be uh
proof systems I'll talk about all of
these three programs shortly um and then
the program will also have several
parallel themes exploring uh you know
the the connections between theoretical
Cs and cryptography uh Quantum
cryptography something Sandy already
talked about as well as other topics
like low complexity crypto I just didn't
have a better picture so I put you all's
picture here as a representative of this
area um um so let me talk a little bit
about the main themes so the First theme
is uh program of fation which is
essentially uh a technique for taking a
computer program and converting it into
a new program which is completely
unintelligible that is you cannot
reverse engineer it you cannot figure
out what are the internal details of the
new program and this is essentially a
great tool to hide Secrets within
programs and as you can imagine this is
an amazingly powerful object uh
obviously it has applications to topics
like software watermarking uh but it
also has many applications outside
cryptography theoretical CS such as
establishing hardness of various
complexity problems uh differential
privacy meta complexity and more and in
some sense uh we widely believe that
aisc is so powerful that it's
essentially crypto complete in the sense
that most cryptographic problems can be
solved using program
ofation um so there has been a lot of
activity in this area in the last uh
eight years so
um after a long line of research we now
actually have general purpose ofation
from well steady resumption so this has
been a major breakthrough that happened
two years ago uh but despite all this
progress this area is still pretty much
in its infancy in the sense that uh
while we have now uh constructions from
well studied assumptions we still don't
know a lot uh in in this in this area so
for example we don't know how to build
uh postquantum Solutions so Solutions
based on assumptions that cannot be
broken by quantum computers Uh current
Construction do use some assumptions
that can be broken uh by quantum
computers um the efficiency of the
current Solutions is terrible they're
not even close to implementable so
there's a lot to be done in that regime
and we also have open questions with
regards to uh uh the kind of security
properties that we can
achieve okay so the second topic is
secure multiparty computation this is
essentially a way for a group of parties
to compute to jointly compute on their
on their inputs while maintaining the
privacy of their inputs that is the
participants only learn the output of
the computation and nothing else you can
also think of MPC as essentially a way
to eliminate single points of failure in
a distributed computation sort of an
analogy can be drawn to eror correcting
codes now in the in the context of uh
distributive
computation um so for this reason uh
secure multiparty computation is very
very useful in Building decentralized
Systems that is where you can uh
distribute trust amongst multiple IES
and allow them to compute on their
private inputs has lots of applications
I'll just point out uh applications to
Federated learning where this model
seems to be quite
useful and again there has been lots of
progress in this area um before uh 2015
we only knew how to achieve sublinear
communication that is you know allow
parties to compute on their input such
that the communication is sublinear in
the size of the computation we only knew
how to do this using the general tool of
fully orphic encryption but now we can
actually do it even without pleomorphic
encryption which is amazing we can even
achieve sublinear time computation in
some uh in some uh functionalities such
as private information retrieval uh back
to F we have had a lots of efficiency
improvements in this area and we have
also made progress in uh settling open
questions related to minimal assumptions
for MPC but still many open questions
remain in this area both on assumptions
and efficiency
front um the third theme the final theme
that I want to talk about it relates to
cryptographic proofs um so this is
essentially um uh you know similar to
mathematical proofs in the sense that
aover can prove a claim uh the
correctness of a claim to a verifier and
we have standard soundness property that
if the claim is false then the Prov
should fail in convincing the verifier
what makes cryptographic uh proof Stand
Out is their ability to have uh
seemingly magical properties uh the
first is that we can make proofs very
very short even smaller than the the
size of the NP computation in this in
this example and the verification can
also be very very fast so this is called
succinctness or succinct proofs and the
second property is zero knowledge which
basically says that the proof reveals
nothing beyond the fact that the
statement is true so again as you could
you could imagine these uh such proof
systems have lots and lots of
applications uh the signature schemes
that we currently use in practice most
of them have their roots in
cryptographic proofs if proofs are small
and they're efficient to verify it also
allows us to delegate computation to
Cloud computer uh you know Cloud
computers and then we can actually
verify very quickly that the computation
was done correctly without having to
redo it ourselves and um again the fact
that the proofs are small and they also
maintain privacy of the witness uh has
lots of applications in
blockchains so in this area a lot of
progress that happened in recent years
primarily focused on uh on the setting
where the proofs are one message so the
pro just simply sends one message to the
verifier who can verify it similar to
mathematical proofs so now we actually
know how to build uh uh non-interactive
zero knowledge proofs from assumptions
that we didn't know for a long time so
for example we even have um
non-interactive zero knowledge proofs
that are postquantum
secure we can also build succinct proofs
now from standard assumptions for many
sub classes of NP something we didn't
know for a long time but now we can do
it um and in the efficiency side there
are now numerous practical constructions
of these objects which are actually used
in practice in fact many many uh
companies startups are focusing on this
area because of the the tremendous
success that has happened uh but there
are still many open questions uh regards
with regards to assumptions and
efficiency for example can we actually
make them so efficient that we can just
make programs self-certifying you know
program can prove that it's not a
malware right that would be
amazing so I want to take a step back
and just mention that uh you know wild
cryptography in general has enjoyed a
strong Synergy in the theory and applied
side this has only improved in the
recent years again just due to the
success uh that has happened the
publication rate of crypto papers in
security conferences only increased uh
there are more and more programs um from
government agencies and and and private
companies for supporting accelerated
transition from to practice in general
there's just more awareness in
cryptography which is
great and uh again because of all of the
success um there's a improved Synergy in
the Academia and Industry industry
worlds more and more companies uh you
know focusing on uh crypto cryptography
related products both in the in the
setting of cryptographic proofs and also
in the setting of uh MPC F and so
on so hopefully uh you know to build
upon all of this success uh we'll have a
uh will uh we'll be able to build up on
the success in the cryptographic program
in 2025 and to see thank
[Applause]
you thank you and we will uh take a
quick break and we can in about 15
minutes